>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE WAR HAS BEEN POSTPONED, IT
TURNS OUT.
A DAY AFTER THE ISLAMIC REPUBLIC
OF IRAN FIRED A SALVO OF CRUISE
MISSILES INTO U.S. BASES IN
IRAQ.
THE PRESIDENT'S ANNOUNCED IRAN'S
MISSILES HAD LANDED HARMLESSLY.
TURNED OUT TO BE A PURELY
SYMBOLIC BOMBING DESIGNED TO
STOP RATHER THAN START A LARGER
WAR.
AS THE PRESIDENT EXPLAINED, AT
LEAST FOR NOW, THE HOSTILITIES
ARE OVER.
>> OUR GREAT AMERICAN FORCES ARE
PREPARED FOR ANYTHING.
IRAN APPEARS TO BE STANDING DOWN
WHICH IS A GOOD THING FOR ALL
PARTIES CONCERNED AND A VERY
GOOD THING FOR THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: A VERY GOOD THING FOR
THE WORLD.
THAT'S A BIG CLAIM.
BUT IN THIS CASE, IT IS NOT AN
OVERSTATEMENT.
FOR THE PAST FIVE DAYS, ALL OF
US HAD HAD A CHANCE TO RUMINATE
ON WHAT WAR WITH IRAN WOULD MEAN
FOR US IN THE UNITED STATES.
VERY EASILY, IT COULD BECOME A
CATASTROPHE.
WE OUGHT TO BE SAYING PRAYERS OF
THANKS THAT IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
WE'RE STILL CLOSE TONIGHT.
THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN TROOPS
REMAIN STATIONED IN IRAQ.
THAT'S A COUNTRY THAT IS LARGELY
RUN BY IRAN.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
AFTER NEARLY 17 YEARS OF
AMERICAN OCCUPATION, IRAN'S MOST
POWERFUL MILITARY LEADER WAS
FLYING IN AND OUT OF BAGHDAD'S
AIRPORT LIKE HE OWNED IT.
THAT'S HOW COMFORTABLE HE FELT
IN IRAQ.
A PLACE WE SUPPOSEDLY CONTROL.
NOW THE GOVERNMENT OF IRAQ,
NEEDED TO BE CREATED OUT OF
NOTHING AND UNTOLD BILLIONS
PROPPING UP MORE THAN A DECADE,
IS TAKING IRAN'S SIDE IN THIS
DISPUTE AND DEMANDING THAT
AMERICANS LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
SO 17 YEARS, TRILLIONS OF
AMERICAN DOLLARS, MORE THAN
35,000 AMERICANS KILLED OR
WOUNDED, YOU PROBABLY KNOW ONE,
AND THIS IS WHAT WE GET AT THE
END IN RETURN.
ANOTHER IRANIAN PROXY STATE THAT
HATES US.
IT'S INFEWE
IT'S INFURE
IT'S INFURIATING.
IT'S IMMORAL.
THE CASUAL RECKLESSNESS.
IT'S ALL AN INSULT TO THE MEMORY
OF THE THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
WHO DIED IN IRAQ.
IT'S ONE OF THE SADDEST THINGS
AMERICA HAS EVER DONE.
THERE MAY BE AN UPSIDE TO ALL OF
THIS SADNESS.
IRAQ'S DEMOCRATIC ELECTED
GOVERNMENT HAS ASKED US TO
LEAVE, AND WE SHOULD LEAVE,
IMMEDIATELY.
REMAINING IN IRAQ INCREASES THE
POWER OF BUREAUCRATS AND THINK
TANKS IN WASHINGTON.
IT DOES DO THAT.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE IN FAVOR OF
IT.
AS THE LAST WEEK HAS SHOWN, IT
IMPERILS THE LIVES OF AMERICANS,
AND FOR NO GOOD REASON.
WE CAN'T TURN IRAQ INTO BELGIUM.
WE TRIED THAT.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
IT'S NEVER GOING TO WORK.
WE DON'T NEED THEIR OIL ANYMORE.
WE'VE GOT FRACKING NOW.
IT'S TIME TO GO.
OH, BUT YOU CAN'T JUST LEAVE
IRAQ SCREAM THE THINK TANKERS
AND TV WAR PLANNERS.
IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE.
THEY MISS THE IRONY.
BUT YOU CAN'T LEAVE.
ACTUALLY, YOU CAN.
HERE'S HOW IT'S DONE.
>> HOW DOES THE UNITED STATES
GET OUT OF THIS SITUATION?
>> HOW DO THEY GET OUT?
THEY GET OUT.
DECLARE VICTORY AND LEAVE.
I'LL TELL YOU, THIS COUNTRY IS
JUST GOING TO GET FURTHER BOGGED
DOWN.
THEY'RE IN A CIVIL WAR OVER
THERE, WOLF.
THERE'S NOTHING WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DO WITH A CIVIL WAR.
THEY ARE IN A MAJOR CIVIL WAR.
IT'S GOING TO GO TO IRAN.
IT'S GOING TO GO TO OTHER
COUNTRIES.